95 just bishop e3 all of a sudden the  white king is safe why is the pawn up  and by wesley give us the queen  d takes c6 no but this is this is not  good  it is not  but  even more suspense  rook takes d2 clearly the obvious move  here but even stronger was b takes c  obviously i know this because i have the  computer running not allowing this pawn  to get to b7 and white cannot keep the  queen  because  rook d1 check is a powerful threat and  if let's say queen e1 bishop d3 picks it  up  but in the game aryan took rook takes d2  now at least the white pawn makes it to  b7  making this a mess but it's still better  for black bishop e4 here gets rid of the  dangerous bishop  yeah  wesley  you don't have to go too crazy  maybe he just missed that bishop before  as possible maybe he's banking on you  know rookie one why is winning again  what they're tired